ranked is kind of screwed up right now
there's trolls everywhere and High ELO
players are dealing with win traders who
are throwing their games for crypto bets
but one man has had enough Tarik just
made his own server for top players and
streamers to play in peace but will it
save ranked
[Music]
so it's no secret that ranked in any
valorent is pretty bad right now High
ELO pros and streamers are stuck queuing
with and against a bunch of trolls and
then there's the crypto betters that I
talked about a couple weeks ago there's
still wind trading their way into High
ELO getting into streamers matches and
then placing bets and throwing to make
sure that they make their money and
after that Tarik began talking about
creating a pro 10 server so players can
avoid all this [__] what am I trying
to achieve with this pro hub I'm trying
to achieve all the top best players in
any playing together in customs so that
we don't have to deal with the drama of
ranked and that the level of play is
higher that clip was from over two weeks
ago now and since then he's been working
behind the scenes to get everything set
up and this past weekend we finally saw
his idea come to life
swing it's still it's still don't worry
beautiful
who said that no it's okay
Tarik calls the server Pro City and it's
been a lot of fun to watch viewers get
to see some of the best players in N A
compete against each other in custom
matches where they get much better
practice than they wouldn't ranked and
if you're wondering how exactly these
players are invited or how they can
apply to join the server then luckily
Tarik provided more info on that front I
guess it's like direct invites
and then this is how do you apply to
join the applications are not up yet but
this would be like you have to meet one
of these to apply which one so anyone
playing for a partner team a
Challenger's roster or a tier one org
are automatically invited which is great
because we even get to see game changers
players like floor pop the [__] off and
once the application process does open
up we'll see more pros and High ELO
content creators who meet any of the
three criteria that tarek listed
although Tarik seems to be the
Mastermind behind all this he's not the
only one who decides who gets in that
decision ultimately lies with the
council and the council is not known by
anyone so that way they can't get
harassed
um so it's me and six other people that
will make those decisions and then if
people get reported basically the
council will vote eventually if someone
gets enough reports on their removal Pro
city has only hosted matches for a few
days now but everyone loves it
especially the pros the pro City 10
bands are literally everything that
we've wanted and ranked it's not too
serious that like uh you can just show
up uh you like you have to do like Civil
War can come up with this insane strats
to be able to like bring to every game
but there is this level of teamwork in
uh this environment that helps simulate
you know real match experience and I
think it's also just really fun to play
and like get a sense of like okay this
is what like just five people with just
good fundamentals play like now as great
as Pro city is the question Still
Remains when will Riot fix ranked Tarik
basically just went and created his own
version of League's Champions Q because
ranked is just that bad for those of you
who don't know know Champions Q is
basically an official game mode in
League of Legends that allows players on
partnered teams and their Academy
rosters to play amongst each other for
better practice and now in valorant
plenty of other players are making their
own servers too so ranked could be
completely dead and High ELO soon it's
been three months since Riot announced
their new competitive game mode but
Brazil's still the only region to have
tried it and players across the world
who just narrowly missed out on
Challengers are dying to compete even if
Riot does ban all the trolls and crypto
throwers these players want something
more and Premiere could be exactly that
the global head of valorant Esports Leo
Faria appeared on the wise men podcast
last week and he did give us a bit of an
update Premier has got me right and you
might have heard because we did a fade
in Brazil we did some early
announcements and we think that will be
really really awesome right it's going
to cover that gap between ranked play
and the professional League
and it's going to give that opportunity
for people who want to participate in
organized play without necessarily being
in the professional leagues
um and are really excited we know it's a
big challenge to bunch of games drive it
for to create that in-game experience
it's hard
we're really really excited really
encouraged so by the sounds of it
Premiere is exactly what some of these
players are looking for essentially a
higher Stakes version of ranked where
they actually have a viable path back
into the pro scene Riot did give us a
bit more info regarding Premiere in this
week's Dev diary but they still haven't
mentioned any release date with rosters
dropping like flies and players
contemplating whether or not they even
want to continue to pursue a career in
valorence I think Riot really needs to
implement Premiere sooner than later I
think what Tarik is doing with his Pro
city server is great but I don't really
see it as a permanent solution it's a
lot of fun to watch and the level of
play is definitely high but it's wild
that he even had to create it in the
first place so hopefully it puts more
pressure on Riot to hurry up with
Premiere because right now there are a
lot of great players who are ready to
step away from valorant for good
he's not the only one who decides who
gets in that decision ultimately lies
with the council
the [__] Council
sounds so mysterious our only desire is
the true Evangelion it's Awakening will
coincide with the resurrection of Lilith
and Usher in the time of